字幕: Moe Serizawa
校正: Koichiro Yoda
こんにちは
（こんにちは）
「キミは なにがやりたいわけ？」
「なにもできないんです」
「だったら なんでもやってみるんだよ」
「はい 分かりました」
そんな他愛もない会話から始まった仕事
来ることすべてを
魅力的に変えるという
変わった会社に
私は入れていただきました
次々と繰り出される
難問珍問に答えながらも
一向に相手にされない毎日でした
「一体 どうして私は ここに入れて
いただいているんだろう？」と思いながらも
途方に暮れる時間を過ごしていましたが－
「古いお城の天守閣が
時々 回るなんてどうですか？
何の前触れもなく 時々」と私が答えると
ボスが
「キミ 本を読まない方がいいよ
キミの持ってる感覚は
何かに影響されると
どんどん薄くなると思うから
いいのよ 無知で
ちょっとバカな方が
気付くことが沢山あるわけよ」
そんな 褒められてるのか貶されているのか
分からないリアクション
でも その ものすごく説得力のある言葉が
いつも私に力をくれました
そんなボスは その昔
若い頃ですね
40回も面接を受けたけれども
一向に雇ってもらえず
そして とうとう 今の仕事に
辿り着いたとこぼしていました
路頭に迷った挙句
テキ屋の親分とポーカーをして勝って
場所をもらえて
それで たらこの販売を
させてもらえるようになったと
でも ナマモノですから
全然売れないし どんどん腐るので
そこで考えたのが
「たらこスパゲッティ」だったそうです
「作り方をプリントして
近所の奥さんに配りだしたら
どんどん売れるようになったんだよね
あれ 考えたの僕だから」
たらこスパゲッティの発祥が
こんなところにあったなんて
実は そのボスは
みなさんもご存知な
沢山のブランド名や商品名の
生みの親でもあるんです
私は そんなボスのもとで 毎日
楽しんで たくさんの仕事をしました
何でもやりました
取材もしました
文章も書きました
使いっ走り、編集の手伝い、撮影撤収作業
ビラ配り、カラオケ接待
スタンドインのモデルも
そんなある日 ボスから
「毎日新聞の季刊誌『活人』で
衣装製作の仕事をしてみなさい」
と命じられました
私は「毎日新聞だったら新聞紙を使って
服を作ってもいいですか？」と申し出て
摩訶不思議な 新聞紙のドレスを纏った
11人の個性的な女の子たちを
作り上げました
『レ・ジョーナリエール』
なんちゃってフランス語で
それらしいタイトルをつけました
そんなことが高じて 衣装製作が生業に
その後
『CORAZON』という
スタイリストの会社を立ち上げて
今に至るというわけです
『CORAZON』とは スペイン語で
「心」イコール ハートという意味です
もとはといえば そのボスと出会う前
私は 憧れの
ファッションブランドのデザイナー
こぐれひでこさんのアトリエで
営業の仕事をさせてもらっていました
軽やかで 小粋で
元気の出る特効薬みたいだった
その服に合わせて
髪をベリーショートの刈り上げにして
毎日 楽しくふわふわと仕事をしていたら
広告や雑誌のモデルを
頼まれるようになり
最後には「歌手として歌を
歌ってみないか？」ということにまで
そのとき声をかけてくれた
張本人こそが
ひでこさんの友人でもあった
そのおかしなボス
人呼んで「おもしろ師」
スーパーエディターの 今は亡き
秋山道夫さんだったのです
私は 完璧だと思うものよりも
どこかひしゃげていたり
はぐれもののように
孤独感を醸し出しているような
そんなものにとても魅力を感じてしまうんです
「そんなものが
ひとたび輝いて見えたりしたら
完璧な美しいものよりも
何十倍も魅力を放つに違いない」
そんなことを考えながら
スタイリストの仕事をしていると
「あんなものがあったらいいのにな
こんなものがあったらいいのにな」
と思うことがよくありました
その中の一つで
ジュエリーがありました
ある日 友人が
とあるジュエリー作家の方を
紹介してくださって
自分のデザインするジュエリーを
作ってみることにしました
２つ ３つと モチーフは増えて
それを仕事で持ち歩くと
女優さんやモデルさんから
それを買いたいとおっしゃって
いただくことが増え
そうこうしているうちに
あるドラマで女優さんが
つけてくださることになりました
「ブランド名は？」と聞かれて
「あ じゃあ考えなくちゃ」
ってことになったんです
ジュエリーというと
格調高くてゴージャス
というイメージがありますが
私が欲しいのは そうではない
密やかだけど 存在感があって
でも 妙に印象的で
身につける人に寄り添い
気持ちをすこーしだけ上げてくれる
ナチュラルメイクのようなジュエリー
何だろうそれは？
密かなもの... 微かなもの？
微かなジュエリー！
そんなネーミングを探すために
「かすか」という言葉がないか
辞書を引いてみました
そしたら あったんです
スペイン語の意味は
「あばら屋」でした
「え？あばら屋？朽ち果てた家？」
そう思った途端に
子供の頃
友達と放置されている空き家に基地を作って
宝物の隠し場所にしていたときの
ことが思い出されたんです
ガラクタや
角が丸くなって落ちていた
綺麗な青いガラス瓶のかけらや
不思議な形の石や
感動した風景
朝露に濡れて
キラキラと輝く蜘蛛の巣とか
流れ星の残像とか
母の鏡台の引き出しの奥に忘れられていた
古びた指輪や壊れた腕時計
使い込まれて傷ついてはいるけれど
その傷は 磨くとまるで独特なカットを
施したようにキラキラと輝く
その傷１つひとつに
想いや命があるかのように
私が魅力的だと思うのは
こういうことだったんだと
やっと気付いたんです
人は 沢山の経験をして
身も心も傷を負い
はたまたシワも寄ってきて
でも その全てを受け入れ
重ねた年相応に自分のものにして
チャーミングな魅力に
変えていくのは
その人自身の力です
心の傷も顔のシワも
様々な輝きに変えたい
静かに 控えめに
しかし 印象的に輝く
独特な輝きで
そんな想いをもって
誕生したジュエリーですが
ドラマで使われて問い合わせが殺到し
それに背中を押される形で
ホームページを立ち上げて
通信販売を始めました
私は 基本的に 時代に
左右されないものが好きです
ありきたりなネックレスチェーンに
少しカットを施して光の反射を多くしたり
職人さんにモチーフの上から
タッチを加えてもらって
そこが チラチラ キラキラと
輝くように工夫したりしていることで
映像では 思いのほか
目を引くようです
その不思議な輝きで
印象的な存在感を残すのかもしれません
突然のアクシデントに見舞われたとき
今まで味わったことの
ないような想いが巡り
何かに気付かせてもらう
ことってありませんか？
私も 沢山の人と出会い 別れ
恋愛の山、谷、崖っぷち
裏切り、離婚、結婚
出産、子育て、病気
最近でも大きな怪我をしました
でも そんなことを経験する度に
何かを得てきたと実感しています
失敗だってそうです
間違ってしまったことって
とっても愛しくて かわいい物なので
お茶目だなって思うんです
だからその失敗を無駄にせずに
デザインに変えてしまう
その結果が想像を遥かに超えた
素敵なものになり
思いも寄らない作品に生まれてしまう
ことだってあると思うんです
失敗は どれだけしてきたかが財産ですよね
「それを無駄にすることなく
大切で豊かな輝きに変えられたら」
そんな想いをもって誕生した
ジュエリーの
そのモチーフ１つひとつに
私は 名前をつけることにしました
何かに喩えてみた方が
イメージが湧くのではないかと
思ったからです
風に乗って浮遊する
植物の胞子のように見える
華奢なクロスには「ハッカ」
小学校の教室に
球根栽培の花としてあった
あの楕円形な形を
思わせるモチーフには
「ヒヤシンス」
笑った顔のモチーフに「ニコ」
動物でも 友達でも
名前で呼んだ途端
親しみが湧くものですよね
その昔 おかしなボスは
全ての人、もの、こと、空間に
愛情を傾け 慈しみながら
面白おかしく世に出す仕事をしていました
私は それを傍らで見ていて
いつしか そんなことが
身についてしまったのだと思います
「どんなことでもやればいいよ
やってみるんだよ
やりたいんなら
できないことはないんだよ
ほら できたじゃない」
そんな 無責任のようでいて
後ろでしっかり受け止めてくれる言葉は
今でも時々 天から降りてきて
私を励ましてくれます
そんな想いを纏うように身につける
お守りのように
ジュエリーって ある種
そんな安心感を添えてくれる
宝物だと思うんですよね
大切な宝物は
肌身離さず身につけていたい
でも 少し気分が変わって
宝石箱の中に置き去りに
することがあったとしても
暗がりの中でそっと静かに輝いて
宝物としての誇りは
決して失わないで欲しい
そんな想いを込めて
私は これからも
ジュエリーをみなさんに
お届けしていきたいと思っています
そして
何かに気付かせて下さる
沢山の人 もの ことに
感謝の気持ちを持って
私は これからも
ものづくり 衣装づくり
そして スタイリングを
続けていこうと思います
ありがとうございます
（拍手）